[Music]
it's like being part of the Bible oh
Christ no that you can sit up it's like
being part of something much bigger than
just making a movie that was like John
Lennon said the Beatles are bigger than
Jesus every day there was a Star Wars
moment we went bloody hell you said to
yourself I'm in Star Wars I have a bad
feeling about this
now I got to choose my lightsaber handle
one day the props master arrived at our
fight studio bit and said them I like to
come and choose your lightsaber
ok then I realized that it was a really
big deal and we went in the props room
and then there was r2d2 and I have
established screaming I realized I go
like that because it was r2d2 I mean it
was like meeting the queen of something
but I remember it's being a big wooden
box with two padlocks on it which he
unlocked and they said are you ready and
I said yeah ready and he opened up it
was like 9 or 10 lightsaber and
different lightsaber handles well they
were all different shapes cut you know I
mean if you look in the film you'll see
that Liam's lightsaber handle it's
different shape to mine
I however got the first choice and I got
the sexier one I would suggest don't
Center on your anxieties everyone keep
your concentration here and now where it
belongs
George was making admit was very always
very keen to assure me that this was a
character and development that he always
used to say because a lot of the time
I'll be just behind Liam here or just
behind Liam here and he always wasn't
there listen you and there's a character
in development so by the time we get to
the second River you know and I always
knew that was the case
[Music]
you